Super Pitfall!
Join Pitfall Harry as he searches a vast subterranean cave dwelling high in the Andes.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sam. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe. What is up, guys?
It's Friday.
It is. It is, yes.
Oh, yes. It's always Friday.
Friday in the appropriate year of the Roman calendar.
That's my favorite year.
Yeah. It's the day you're listening to this.
Yes, exactly. And that's the best day of all.
It is. We always like our listeners listening on the correct day that they choose to listen to.
In the present. So far, nobody has complained about listening to this in the past or the future.
And so today we're going to talk about Super Pitfall, but I feel like we can't really talk about Super Pitfall before we talk about the non-Super Rise version of it.
You know, like the normal version.
They're going to say Pong.
Yeah. Pong is like the normal version of all video games.
Yeah. Like, you know, it's like, oh, can you give me the normal version of Mario Brothers?
That's just Pong. Pong.
Yep. So Pitfall came out on the Atari 2600.
It's pretty much considered the first platformer.
And also it's like an action adventure game, too.
So it's got two things going for it.
And I played it just before we did the podcast and everything like that.
And I think it's still fun and still holds up.
We don't have to go like into the history and everything like that.
But can I just get some general feelings about the first entry, Pitfall?
So I played it a little bit going into this game and I thought it was fun.
I'd seen it so much in, you know, pop culture and stuff.
And the little when he's swinging from the rope, it just cracked me up.
It's still such a good sound, too.
Yeah. It still holds up.
That's supposed to be his voice.
It's yeah, it's like the I didn't realize that either.
It's like a track.
But now that you say he's like, oh, yeah, I thought it was like a Tarzan.
Yeah, like a Tarzan kind of deal.
I never read that. I never did either until I did it because I heard that noise before.
But once I was swinging from the rope, I was like, oh, I get it now.
I died a lot when I was playing and I wasn't very good, but it was still I don't know.
It was still charming and the controls were pretty tight.
And, you know, it's simple, but it's good.
Yeah, I think I mistook the original Pitfall with the original Prince of Persia in my headcanon,
because I was expecting like something a little bit closer to Fidelity when I played it.
But no, I mean, I remembered that from when I was playing on really old systems in my childhood.
But, you know, it's been it's been like two decades.
So I've never really had any experience with this game before,
but I'm glad you said that about Prince of Persia, because that's the first thing that I thought of when I was playing it.
It obviously didn't look like it, but just, yeah, you go from screen to screen and there's like a different little obstacle that you need to take on in each screen.
I thought I thought that was cool.
I think I would have enjoyed it.
Admittedly, I didn't get to actually play this one.
I just watched a video of it, but it looked fun.
Yeah, I definitely think I think to play it.
I think everybody who likes video games should play this game because it's simple enough that there's no entry and you can go play it on the Internet.
It's it's available in a browser.
You might need Java.
Not sure about that. Ooh, Java.
Yeah, Java's on the way out, but not the coffee.
And I will kind of call my coffee Java from time to time.
I think I get that from the road.
I've never met anyone. Would you say a cup of Joe?
Cup of Joe? Yeah, I like cup of Joe as well.
I don't know why Dunkin Donuts has like a...
A box of Joe? Yeah, no, yeah, yeah.
Like they almost have like a copyright on that now.
Like you can't say it without people thinking about Dunkin.
That's my name. Sorry.
Welcome to the club.
Take a second. I've got something in my eye.
Fuck. There's a seltzer.
I gotta like pour the seltzer in my eye.
There's an SCP which produces a liquid...
It's a coffee machine that makes a liquid version of anything.
One of them...
One time someone asked it for a cup of Joe.
And the guy in the room named Joe started feeling sick.
Because he was dispensing his innards.
Yeah, that sucks. That's a cool SCP.
I know that one. Yeah.
Cool. Um...
Here we go. We're gonna start with development.
Okay? And I think that's enough about Pitfall.
Now we're gonna make things super.
We're gonna talk about...
I prefer you wouldn't.
Yeah, yeah. I was saying you don't look very amused over there on the other end of the table, Sean.
But we have to talk about it.
It is today... It is the game of the week.
And we'll start with the development.
So this game was made by Micronics and published by Activision.
Activision's kind of like all over the place with us recently.
But I think I'm also confusing them with Acclaim.
Like, because they both start with...
Hey, I just... The games blend together for me.
And they're both just publishers.
I think that the true red flag here is Micronics.
Okay. Because they don't really have a solid track record with us either.
Mm-hmm. Uh, I don't quite remember the game that I'm thinking of.
But it was very bad. But the name...
Just the fact that the name is sticking with you is also not a great sign of, like, things to come.
And also, Pitfall was made by a guy named David Crane.
And he has nothing to do with Super Pitfall.
So it's just kind of like Activision cashing in on the Pitfall name and saying,
Hey, we can do this.
Let's do this. So they do.
And what do they really take from Pitfall?
You can fall? You can jump?
Well, also, like, in Pitfall, you were searching for 20 treasures.
And in this one, you're searching for, like, three different things.
So the idea of still, like, searching for treasure counts for something, even if treasure is now your niece and your pet.
Pet lion. Yeah.
And all those other things.
Also, Sean, you're thinking of both 1942 and elevator action.
There it is. But, Ghost and Goblins.
So, I mean, but that groundwork was laid out in the arcade version.
And the arcade version is better.
So, I think, like, even though...
Those were not Micronics in the arcade.
No, the arcade was Capcom.
Yeah. There we go. And also, like, some other things I'm noticing now.
Ikari Warriors, they also did.
Tiger Heli.
So, things were made by Micronics around 87.
They're all over the place.
Let's do some first impressions for Super Pitfall.
Sean? I feel like with Super Pitfall, it was, like, sort of stepping into somebody's, like, chewed-up gum.
Because it looks like it was good in its original form.
And now it's just this mass of just, like, icky garbage.
And I'm sort of coloring the rest of my reaction to this game.
But I think that the fact that it's an open world is great.
As far as an open world game can be at this level.
It's just filled with garbage.
Garbage enemies. Garbage platforming.
The jump is bad.
And this is my first impression.
Because this is just thrown at you in the first 20 seconds.
All of these terrible mechanics are just thrust upon you.
And he shoots a gun.
That doesn't hit anything. Alright.
Joe? Yeah.
My first impression was definitely a lot about the controls kind of not feeling great.
And also about, like, the lack of direction.
Like, I wasn't really sure what I'm supposed to be doing.
Am I supposed to get that?
Am I supposed to get the gold? Like, there's a bunch of little things that I just feel like...
Did you read the manual?
I read the manual.
The gold gives you points.
But, I mean, I just felt like, after a while, I was just, like, lost.
And I was just, you know, it wasn't...
I don't know. It didn't...
The gameplay did not make up for the fact that I'm wandering around this world I don't want to want.
Like, there was no fun to wandering around.
Like, if you're lost in a game like that, like, think of Metroid.
You can get lost in that, but you're having fun searching.
And this, I was not having fun off the bat.
Yes. And my first impression is discovered right away when the first ladder in the game is actually just a spike trap with, like, a bat.
Like, it's just a pit of death.
Like, the ladder just ends.
You can't see what's about to happen.
But when you drop down from the ladder, you fall into a pit and die.
And I was like...
What kind of pitfall? Yeah.
On the one hand, like, that's...
Well, that's pretty realistic to what would probably happen in a real cave if you followed ladders around.
But on the other hand, I don't need that in a video game.
And I also wish that that information was communicated better on a screen of, like, being able to see what you're going to fall down to.
This is going to be a huge problem throughout the rest of the game.
But I just think it's so weird that in the very first thing you're introduced to is don't trust ladders.
When climbing ladders is most of the game.
It is good advice, though, for this game.
I get the feeling that they were trying to do the tutorial like Mario does in the first few seconds of where it's like, oh, this is what you need to do.
But instead, it kind of just comes off as, like, this game's going to suck.
Don't try anything.
Don't try anything but funny.
It comes off as, like, you can't trust what you're seeing.
And, like, there's not really going to be a clue to what you're supposed to, like, what you can climb down and what you can't.
You can't trust what you see.
You can't trust what you do.
Right. You know, it's, you can't really trust this game.
And that goes straight through to the end of the game.
You can't trust what's happening.
Because, like, we'll get into that later, I'm sure.
All right. So, as I do, I like to read the manual first.
So, while I was looking up the manual, this is, like, before first impressions.
These are, like, pre-impressions.
I looked up Super Pitfall.
And the first thing, one of the first things that comes up is map.
Or, like, route. And so I'm thinking, okay, cool.
This is, this is interesting that there's, you know, a specific way you have to go through.
So before I even read the manual, I knew that it was some kind of open world-ish kind of game.
And then I read the beginning of the manual, which said that there are over 270 different screens in this game.
And that's when the red flags started to come up.
Because with a game with that many screens, they can't all be good.
You know, it's got to be just a bunch of useless stuff.
And then my suspicions were pretty much confirmed when I got in.
But I think the most jarring thing off the bat is that, I don't know, 15-second song that repeats.
Not the best song either.
Like, 15-second songs can be okay certain times.
Not when they're not clutch.
Besides that, one positive thing that I liked was that, depending on how quickly you press the A button, your character jumps different heights.
Which I thought was, you know, they did it in, you know, Super Mario Bros.
But for a game that looked and felt this bad, I thought that that was kind of a cool thing right off the bat.
That you can kind of do little jumps if you want to not hit your head on something.
Sure. But whoever programmed this game did not think it through.
Because I think the controls are some of the poorest that we've played other than wrestling games.
It's real bad. That's the one silver lining.
It's like, oh, I can control my jump height.
Right. That was it. And so, since you mentioned the manual, we might as well go into a little Tales from the Manual section.
Because I have two points of information that I'd like to talk about.
The first has nothing to do with the manual.
So, I really got to think of a better name for this Tales from the Manual section.
Tales from the Marketing. Yeah.
Tales from Marketing.
Well, Super Pitfall is actually a loose remake of Pitfall 2 Lost Caverns.
And from what I can tell, it must have been a very loose remake.
Maybe, like, only the plot was carried over.
Because Pitfall 2 The Lost Caverns seems like a decently playable game that Pitfall fans probably liked.
It was sort of like Pitfall in some way?
In some ways, but also, like, the idea that you're exploring caves and stuff this time instead of, like, a jungle.
Okay. Pitfall 1 is all, like, in a jungle.
And then, in the manual for Super Pitfall, there's a tips and tricks section, you know, towards, like, the end of it.
And it tells you, like, a bunch of things that, of pieces of advice that you might need to play the game and to get through the game properly.
And we've seen this before in other manuals.
Sometimes it gives you, like, a riddle or, like, a vague hint.
Or there's that other one about the Medusa in Starforce that was, like, it's worth a million points.
Can you find it?
Well, in Super Pitfall, the manual just tells you that the best way to get through the cave is to explore it.
That's not even, like, that would make sense if it was in the objective or in, like, the beginning of the manual.
But in the tips and tricks section, it's the only thing you can do.
Didn't we just have another game like that where it's directions on how to play were just, like, beat the game?
No, it was just over description of, like, pressing A button will do what the A button does.
Whereas, yeah, the best way to explore the cave is to explore it.
And it's like, thanks.
Yeah. And then they do it again.
But there's only one way to play the game, right?
Like, you would have to explore the cave.
It's literally the only, it's, no one ever got confused about that.
No one started the game, dropped it in the cave, and said, I shouldn't be here.
And, like, put down the console and control it.
But then right after that, they have tried to discover the shortest route.
You may just uncover an unexpected shortcut in the process.
So, by searching for the shortest route, you may find the shortest route.
Or an even shorter route than you were expecting.
Yeah. Right. I was always expecting very long routes because, you know, and we'll get into this in the gameplay section,
but navigating your way through this cave is kind of like, if you fall deep enough into the cave,
you're kind of stuck there for a while.
Like, you know, you're not about to just be like, oh, it'll just be like, you know,
a couple seconds before I'm back up at the top.
No, you're down there.
Yeah, yeah. If you fall off of, like, one level, but there just happens to be the right kind of,
or the wrong kind of area below you, you'll just fall for, like, 40 minutes.
You'll fall for 40 minutes, and then there's nothing you can do about it.
You're passing things that it looks like you can land on.
You can't.
You can't move your player, correct?
Right. You have a certain amount of jump control, but that's only once you've hit the top of your arc.
Not once you, like, fall.
No, yeah, but once you're falling, you can't, like, will yourself a certain way.
Like, in Super Mario Bros., when you fall from any height, you can still control Mario's momentum.
Not so in Super Pitfall.
You are locked to a free fall, straight down.
Like, put the controller down, have a bathroom break.
You're going to be falling for a while.
So, real fast, I'll do the objective here.
In Super Pitfall, you have to locate a diamond, your niece, and your pet quickclaw, who is a lion, as Sam mentioned earlier.
And you do this through a vast set of cave, of one cave.
I was going to say caves. Vast set of cave.
Honestly, you know, with the way these translations work out sometimes, that might have been in the game.
Yeah. You're given no map.
You must explore the cave.
And there's zero guidance to find any of those things.
So, if you want to find the diamond, the niece, your pet quickclaw, the manual wasn't telling you anything.
But the game isn't also telling you anything either.
There's no character in the game who says, like, hey, I think your niece is this way.
Or, like, a sign with your niece or something like that.
Like, anything that would help you.
You just have to kind of explore the cave and figure out where those things are.
You're limited to jumping, climbing ladders, and shooting a gun.
One hit and you're dead.
Similar games we've played are Spelunker and Metroid.
I think that's my objective setup.
So, now that everybody understands the game that we're talking about, I'm sure they're picturing it vividly in their heads, we can talk gameplay.
Who wants to start?
I'll start real quick.
While you may be vividly imagining what the game is like, it's very much not that.
Because if you are thinking, like, okay, you go around, you search for keys, and then they'll unlock doors.
Like, yeah, there are keys and there are doors, but you can't see the keys.
And you really can't see the doors.
And you also don't really see much of anything.
Because everything that you're trying to find does not have a sprite until you jump and get it.
Like, you won't even get it just walking around.
They're hidden so poorly.
Like, it's not even a fun experience, I think.
I feel like maybe some people did, but...
It's not because here's why also.
Like, so you said with enemies just kind of pop in, right?
Like, all of a sudden a frog is like mid-jump, even though you didn't see him a second ago.
And then you just take one step back and he despawns, right?
It's like, oh, great job, programmers.
Like, I'll just glitch my way through the cave that I'm clearly hallucinating.
It's hallucinating.
And just, like, perfectly sync up over and over and over again on loop so that you can't get through anything.
And so in that situation, you have to kind of, like, leave that area and come back and hope that the waterfall, like, recesses itself properly.
Yeah. And so, like, good job there, too.
I think we can talk a lot about, like, the glitches and errors of this game, though.
Because even just...
Even when it's performing...
Even when it's acting as it should, it performs terribly.
Right. Nothing about this game's controls are satisfying.
Because even shooting your gun, right?
Like, you would expect, like, okay, I shoot the gun.
The bullet comes out.
There's the spider.
And then it just goes right past the spider.
It's like... Yeah. And then I realized, oh, no, that's just something that can never be killed.
Yeah, you can kill spiders.
You're supposed to... I don't know if it works on spiders or not, but you're supposed to, like...
There's little dips that have, like, a small ladder or a small area you can, like, go in.
And if you go in there, jump up a little bit and shoot, the bullet will be at the right level to hit those lower things.
Those situations are so rare.
But at that point, you're better off just jumping over these.
Yeah, really. They're also harmless.
It's weird, because you can crouch.
And I thought maybe that's why you would tell you to do that.
What does that do? It doesn't do anything.
Because your hitbox, even when you're standing, doesn't affect your head.
Yeah. Well, I guess there's, like, the bats that, like, fly in that little swoopy pattern.
The hitbox is the same.
Yeah? The hitbox is the same.
Those bats really angered me.
So I think, like, one thing, though, is, like, we're talking about frogs.
We're talking about spiders.
We're talking about bats.
The cave's got a variety of enemies.
The problem is that there's no way to handle these enemies.
Yeah. The only thing you can do is shoot a frog in the face.
If it's a midjump.
Oh, and the scorpions, too.
Those things got me. Yeah, and they charge at you, too.
They run at you. Yeah, so they give you, like, a nice variety of enemies.
But the problem is that the way that the game controls itself, you can't really handle any of these enemies properly.
Maybe if it were less crowded.
It's a very crowded cave.
And I sometimes will just have to avoid just going anywhere where there's any kind of resistance.
Because I just die so often.
And you only get three tries.
So you don't really want to risk it.
Like, the design of the game actually punishes you for exploring in some ways.
Yeah. Well, I think the biggest thing that punishes you for exploring at all, and, you know, to Pitfall's, like, you know, credit, this is one of the things that the original game had going for it was, like, the traps and the, you know, like, avoid the alligators when their mouths are open.
Or, you know, like, don't fall into the pits, you know?
Like, that makes sense. It kind of telegraphs that stuff to you.
Right, it telegraphs that stuff to you.
In this game, it's filled with different kinds of traps, but none of them you're prepared for because they're a screen over that you fall into, or they're as you're coming up to them, like, a new enemy is there.
The ceiling will just spontaneously fall with no, like, when you're under it.
Yeah. All of a sudden, a, you know, there's a part where the top of the ceiling of the cave kind of collapses onto you.
So, and, like, cool idea, you know, I think, like, also that would kill anybody and should realistically block the path back the other way.
But if you want to do it in the game, I'm fine with that, but also it's just, it was never communicated to that point, so you're absolutely going to die the first time it happens.
And is it only the one spot?
I feel like maybe I just, like, backtracked.
I feel like it just happens at some spots, and there's no way of knowing what's going to happen.
It's not really a puzzle, it's just, you're going to die.
That's it. I don't think they're random, but I definitely think it happens, like, in multiple places throughout the game.
I think the game exposes you to a lot early on in terms of exploration.
Like, you can go a bunch of different ways and experience a bunch of different things, but after a while, you've kind of seen the cave.
Yeah. And now you're just kind of like, where is any of the things I need to find, right?
Like, how did people do on finding the diamond, the niece, or the pet?
I found the diamond.
And that's it.
I didn't find anything.
Also, I just wanted to note that in the manual, even when you find Rhonda, it says that she's been turned to stone,
and so that you have to find a flask of medicine also.
So that's not even...
Yeah, but that's like, yeah, that's like the twist early on.
Yeah, but it tells you that first thing in the manual also.
Right, but I guess, like, you know, it's the prologue of the game.
Not that anybody would stick around for longer than the prologue.
Yeah. I wouldn't recommend it.
So we have issues with the jump.
We have issues with the gun.
There's a lot of enemies, but they're too small to even hit with your gun.
We didn't even talk about the limited ammunition.
So in your gun, you get, I think, 12 bullets?
20. 20? Who cares?
Yeah. That's how I, when I ran out of bullets, I was like, all right, I just won't shoot anymore.
It hasn't done anything for me.
Yeah, they tried to make it like a use them carefully because these are precious and you're
going to need them. And it's like, I don't think I really need them.
Like, I'll just, honestly, I'll just, with the frogs, I'll just go the other way.
You know, like, honestly, in this cave, I'm thinking about how do I get back up to where
I came from and just leave?
Yeah. And it's not like the bullets work, also.
I feel like the hitboxes were so bad on the enemies that I would have to shoot the bat
three times before we'd even get hit.
Yeah, and then you're down to 17 and good luck finding more ammo.
There is more ammo, but...
It's hidden the same way that the keys are hidden, where you don't really see it until
you jump up and accidentally touch it.
Right. And that's even how the secret warps are dealt with in this game.
Did we mention there's secret warps?
Yeah, there's secret warps to better manage your trip.
Secret, is that what they say in the mail?
I don't know. Okay. But secret warps in this game work a little differently, though, because sometimes secret
warps are, like, required to get back to other parts of the cave that you maybe fell from
or that you want to get back to.
That doesn't seem like that should be the case.
It should be that any way to get to this cave should be completely explorable.
There should never be, like, a drop-off point unless it was going to act like a Metroidvania
where it's like, once you drop off, you can only get back to the top with the new item.
Yeah. You know? That level of design understanding is beyond the developer of this game.
Yes. One of the warps is actually an enemy that you have to get hit by.
And what's the problem with that, Sean?
The problem with that is that you have been trained from the beginning of this game to
either avoid or destroy enemies.
I mean, it would take you forever to figure that out, even by accident.
Or, like, if you're intentionally doing it, you still don't know which enemy or anything.
Surely the bird is colored differently or looks different.
The bird looks exactly like the other birds that can kill you, Mike.
No way.
It is true.
And I only found this out by watching a video thing later on.
I can't believe that.
That is the kind of stuff that when people say Nintendo hard, that's what I really think about.
No, Nintendo game is designed that way.
Yeah, I know, but I'm saying, like, that's the kind of bullshit I expect from these kinds of games.
But this is the first, like, example I can think of where a game has, like, mandatory parts of it.
Like, sometimes you will need to use that secret warp if you forgot something earlier on to get back to that area.
And it's like, how would that be communicated to anybody?
Were they trying to sell a guidebook later on?
I don't know. That has to be something along those lines, because I know that they did exist.
Like, there were strategy guides.
It's not even clever.
Never. Nowhere.
You know, secret warps existing in an otherwise totally realistic world is, you know, mind-boggling enough.
But then to think, like, oh, and one of those secret worlds would just be a bird that you jump into.
It would be fun if that were, like, an Easter egg.
Or maybe there was...
Takes you to a treasure room.
Yeah. Something like that.
But if it's actually necessary, then no.
No. There was a thing in The Goonies, too, that had that same thing, right?
It was Hit the Woman Five Time.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. And then you get an evident required item.
I don't know if it was a woman, but I think it was.
I think it was an old woman. It was an old lady.
Yeah, an old lady, and you gotta hit her five times.
All right. Whatever. And so, you know, we touched lightly on the exploration thing, I think, for the most part.
I feel good about that.
But can we talk about how there are no cave exploration items to be found in this game?
I felt like a flashlight would have been nice, maybe some hiking gear, like, you know, a hookshot.
Where were these things?
So, all right.
Do you, Mike, you know the trademark swinging ropes, right?
Yes. So those are from Pitfall.
They're also in Pitfall 2.
Super Pitfall, I'm sorry.
Yeah. Well, this is a loose adaptation of Pitfall 2.
Did you notice that they were sort of, like, phasing in and out of existence?
Everything in this game, at one point or another, will phase in and out.
But no, I didn't notice this specific instance.
I think that they pushed the engine.
I mean, I don't even know if it's an engine that they built this game in.
But they pushed the software so hard just to get the ropes to exist in some dimension.
That I don't think that there would be any processing power left to create, like, a hookshot.
Let alone an inventory system, too.
You know? Like, I don't think so.
Yeah. But it's something that I would have liked.
And then, what happens when you beat the game?
Joe. Well, let me break it to you here.
I didn't beat the game.
Okay, that's fair. Do you know?
I did watch the playthrough, and I saw that at the end you get to, what, your niece that you're trying to rescue?
You get her, and then that's, you're still playing the game.
Yes. So you don't even get out, right?
You have to go back somewhere.
But, like, it didn't seem clearly indicated, even once you got there, why you've now, why it's over.
I would imagine that you have to get out first.
I don't know the exact clear conditions.
I just know that when you clear, and we can find out the clear conditions in a minute.
But once you clear the game, all you get is just offer to play in another world.
Oh, yeah. That's the actual ending.
Yeah. And it's just, this new world is just another game of Super Pitfall.
But all of the items are switched to different locations.
Which are already hidden. Like, no thanks.
It was hard enough to find out the first time without any indication of anything.
This is the equivalent of, like, solving a puzzle, you know, like an actual jigsaw puzzle.
And then after you solve it, they give you the option to solve the same puzzle.
Like, you'll complete the same picture, but they change the shape of the jigsaws inside, you know?
That's not helpful.
That's not interesting.
It's also not another realm or another dimension or whatever they said.
Right. It's just, it's just things moved, things in different places.
Let me give you the description of, like, how I watched the game end.
A lot of the things that I've learned about this game, I watched by, I learned by watching an AGDQ run.
What is AGDQ?
Awesome Games Done Quick.
A little speed running marathon that's done two times a year.
Yeah. You got Awesome and then you got Summer Games Done Quick.
Very good. I don't know which one this was.
I think it was Awesome.
But it did it in seven minutes.
And the way he beat the game was he got his niece and then he just died three times and ran out of his lives.
And then he got to the title screen and waited for, like, the demo to run.
And that pretty much works the same as whatever the other endgame, like, flag is supposed to be.
And that's how the game ends, to me.
I'm trying to even figure out how those are, like, accidentally connected.
It's just poor, like, script programming.
Yeah. And so I'm watching it now and it's kind of incredible.
You do have to leave the cave.
You find out that you've been in Egypt this whole time because every game takes place in Egypt at one point or another.
One stage is going to casually reveal to you that there's pyramids in it.
So you see the pyramids and then the game just all of a sudden just starts, like, fluttering between, like, a black strobe and the actual gameplay.
And then it just comes up and says, please try another world.
That sounds like you've got the wrong number.
Yeah. Like, you've been playing the wrong game and they tell you once you've finished it.
Like, oh, wait, this wasn't the game.
That was somebody else's niece.
You have to go back and find your niece.
You don't recognize your own niece?
That was also, like, a gumshoe problem, right?
Later that same day.
Yeah, later that same day she's kidnapped.
That was a good game.
Nah. Let's, um, let's fix this mess.
Would you guys join me in fixing this mess?
Let's, let's, let's think about what we would want in this game to make Super Pitfall a game that you would actually play.
Because I think this is a game that is so bad in terms of how it actually controls and in terms of, like, what they, what they chose to include.
That if we think about what is possible in the realm of the NES, I think I can do this.
I thought this one through.
And so here's what I have, okay?
No traps that you can't see on screen beforehand.
So there's, like, a, a warning or a cue that something's gonna fall apart or that.
A rumble. Yeah, a rumble or something.
Or that, like, a ladder leads to, like, a pit, you know, so you can at least go down there and then be like, I don't really want to fall into that and climb back up.
Things that don't necessarily, like, auto-kill you for a mistake that you wouldn't have made had you have known more information.
Because if you think about it, if you're exploring a cave, there's nothing stopping a guy on a ladder from looking down and saying,
oh, that's a pit, and then going back up.
Because we, the player, can't see that.
I don't think it's fair that our character dies.
Next, I don't think there should be a giant map, but I think that there should have been maps found throughout the game that lead you to the next area you need to go to.
So there's a clear sense of direction that, you know, okay, cool, I've completed, you know, like, the upper right portion of the screen,
and now I need to move, you know, like, just kind of like, here's where you've been, here's where you need to go next.
Something like that.
I would have also liked an above-ground area that you need to deliver things found in the cave.
So, obviously, there would be more here than just your niece, the diamond, and...
You want to introduce more backtracking?
And the pet, but yeah, well, here's the reason why.
It would have made me become more familiar with the layout of the cave,
rather than thinking, like, that the cave is just, I don't know where I am compared to where I'm going.
You'd have to learn the routes between, like, if there's something in the top right of the game,
you'd have to figure out, okay, now how do I get back to the main starting point to deliver and drop off these things?
I'm not saying there would be, like, a marketplace where you actually, like, barter and sell things,
but just almost like...
A home base. Yeah, a home base.
You know what's funny? What you're describing sounds so much like SteamWorld Dig.
Yeah, this is SteamWorld Dig right now.
Have you played that game?
I've played SteamWorld Dig, yes.
But they have marketplaces.
That's funny. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, no. No marketplace.
Just, like, I'm thinking more like the Game & Watch octopus game.
Yeah. Where, like, Mario goes down and he can loot the treasure.
It's not Mario. It's Game & Watch in that one, but I'm thinking of the Game & Watch gallery for Game Boy.
But you loot the treasure for as much as you'd like,
but then your character gets heavier and smaller as you come back up.
And then you just drop off all the coins that you've collected.
Otherwise, if you get caught by the octopus, you lose everything.
So what are your other...
Do you have any more, like, big points?
The other thing I was thinking was more booby traps, not cheap deaths.
Think more, like, Indiana Jones-style booby traps in the cave.
They can shamelessly take, like, a rolling rock.
I would have liked that.
That exists in sort of the Moe I had.
Which is in every game.
We need to talk about the Moe I had.
Every game should have a Moe I had, like, section.
I didn't want to talk about the Moe I had.
It scared you? I'm scared of the Moe I had now.
Well, this one is rather, like, large and...
Imposing. Imposing compared to the other Moe I had we've faced.
But other than the Moe I had, they also have, you know,
the stereotypical action movie Vice Room,
where things just sort of try and crush you.
Yes, which is also in, like, Castlevania.
Yeah. So, I mean, they do exist.
They're just not very well executed.
Which is, yeah, just down to, again,
the poor programming of everything in the game.
I do think, though, that with your changes,
you would also have to change several different core concepts
that govern a lot of these early NES games,
like the idea of one-hit deaths and limited lives.
Because if you're going to be doing...
I feel like the mode of exploration that the designers,
in quotes, of this game were expecting you to do
was you learn the beginning by dying over and over,
and you have to go through it over and over.
When you introduce, well, you have to go back anyway
to deliver your goods.
I think that if you have both the limited amount of lives
and the, I guess, like, restart,
the amount of times that you have to restart
and start from the beginning anyway,
I think that adding more backtracking will be annoying.
But if you have, like, maybe a health bar
and unlimited continues,
then maybe, yeah, that would work.
To be fair, I completely stand by
that every NES game should lose lives
and have a health bar instead of a one-hit death.
However, in this game, I'm cool with a one-hit death
because, like, you're just some random dude
just down in a cave.
Scorpion stings you.
You're dead. Is there still a gun?
There's still a gun, yes.
And it works. It kills all enemies in my version of the game.
I think that there's a precedent for a health bar, though.
Because in the very first Pitfall,
that's how... It's not a health bar, but it's, like, a health number.
Yeah, yeah. You get, like, three, I think.
Three? Before you're, like...
They're basically lives. Right, but when you, like, hit the ground too hard,
your number goes down as well.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. I didn't even connect that.
Yeah. I didn't really know what it did.
I thought it was just my score.
Oh, I assumed that was health.
Maybe I was wrong. Yeah.
But, I don't know.
I think a health bar...
I agree. Yeah.
That's what I gotta say. I agree.
Yeah, no, I would like a health bar in every NES game,
and as you guys know, sometimes I try to, like, track down ROM hacks
that have fixed this in games.
And, lo and behold,
there is a Super Pitfall ROM hack
that goes above and beyond
any ROM hack I've seen for an NES game so far.
Is this the one that was just released?
It was released pretty recently.
Let me check the date for you on this.
Because it's also, like, a remastered version, right?
It was September 5th, 2016.
Okay. But, this is the remastered version.
It does work on a regular NES.
If you have, like, a flash cartridge
that can work on a regular NES
and you plug with this ROM hack in,
it will play properly on original hardware.
The crazy thing is,
it redesigns almost everything about this game.
It's called Super Pitfall 30th Anniversary Edition.
This is what I'm talking about. And it's by, it's a hack by NES Rocks.
I thought he would be known for more
because this is such an amazing ROM hack,
but he's just known as the Super Pitfall guy.
It looks pretty great, too.
I played it. And it is fantastic.
It's got completely new graphics,
a new soundtrack,
a new menu that's more colorful
and plays, like, you know,
like, looks more like Pitfall
and shows the pyramids right off the bat
so there's no, like, confusion about that.
When they say that there's improved performance,
they mean it because even the jump is fixed
and you can move
while you're falling down mid-momentum.
That's cute. The only thing that was kind of weird
with Super Pitfall
was that the gun,
even though it still exists and stuff like that,
it doesn't always seem to trigger
when you want it to.
So that was maybe just like a...
That's just keeping with the Super Pitfall heritage, though.
Yeah, yeah. But there's no more hidden items.
Warps are now doors
instead of just, like,
things you run into.
There's a new HUD inside the game
that explains more things to you.
There are little, like,
level design adjustments
to make sure that the very first ladder
doesn't lead to a pit of death.
Like, that's nice.
And if you can believe it,
it's also...
It's available in English and Portuguese.
So it's not even just a one...
I've always been looking for
that Portuguese experience.
Right, right. And the last thing,
a seamless,
fully automatic save feature.
You just hold reset
while shutting down
and it will avoid save file corruption.
That's fun. Wow.
Good job, NES Rocks.
Crazy. I love it.
I also hope,
because I need to go back
to more bugs, that they fixed
this particular issue.
that they... I think there's...
I think they found a bug,
decided they didn't want to fix it,
and then just made it canon.
But there is...
Like, you notice that
you'll just fall off ladders, right?
Yeah. I've noticed.
I don't think that that was designed.
I think that that was
a problem that they did not fix.
But it is in the manual.
It is in the manual. We were like,
let's just make it look
like we planned it.
So they have to fix that,
but also, if there are...
This is another thing that I learned from
the speedrun.
If you are in a screen
where there are any moving...
any moving sprites at all,
whether it's an enemy
or a moving platform
or something in the background,
you can just phase through walls
if you walk in that direction
for long enough.
And it's just...
All these bugs means
that this game
wasn't even play-tested,
I feel. But Super Pitfall
30th Anniversary Edition
proves that this is all possible.
Like, remember when you were talking earlier about the...
I didn't want to spoil it,
but when you were talking about the ropes
and how they were kind of
like glitching in and out,
that's just like...
That's just because they didn't know
how to code this game properly.
Exactly, yeah. You know, granted,
this is in 2016
where we know a lot more
about programming, but one guy was able
to completely fix this game
and make it into something
that's at least
for Pitfall fans
something more faithful.
I'm not saying that anybody who likes NES games
should try this, but I definitely think
this is more true
to the Pitfall franchise
than Super Pitfall ever was.
Yeah. And it's not like
by 1987
there hadn't been
other games that were at least
as big as Pitfall
that did better.
Yeah. So it's not like
they're like,
ah, we've got to give them a break because
no one knew
how to do this yet. Oh yeah.
No, I didn't give them a break of any kind.
I just imagined that
when I said engine,
I thought I meant
sort of like a
this is beyond
their capability. Yes, completely.
And while we're on
the subject of the ROM hacks,
I just also wanted to talk about it
because we didn't talk about this
in the Goonies 2 episode,
but NES Rocks,
that same guy, also made a Goonies 2
redesign. Cleaning up the entire
entire all the bad ones.
That one I'd be pretty interested to play
because I liked Goonies 2 already.
I mean, it had a lot of problems, but
So I'll just tell you
a few things. The text is now faster.
Pressing the select
button toggles between
hyper and jump shoes
if you have any of those.
This is Goonies 2. Yeah, Goonies 2.
The start button
goes to the map screen
and pausing has been
removed because
obviously, like,
you're paused on the map screen anyway.
There's a better password screen with
more information on
controls and also
way more intuitive
controls. There's a new map
screen showing the location of some
important items right
off the bat. So this way you don't
have to just look around
for things. You know, some people
say it's not necessary,
but I think in today's
day and age it's important to have,
like, something to
start from, not to
just start from the
bare minimum. And you only need to
hit the lady once
instead of five times.
So that's a big
improvement. It's much nicer.
It's still not great,
but it's a little
nicer than five times.
A review in Computer
Gaming World, this is
in 1987, hated
Super Pitfall and
said that it was a
Super Mario Brothers
rehash that most NES
users will be able to
play in their sleep.
Certainly, there is
nothing in the game
itself to keep them
awake. I could agree with the
second sentence.
I have no idea how
this is like Super
Mario Brothers. I am Jump.
And he looks like
Super Mario. This is a lazy review.
The color scheme kind
of looks like the bricks.
Yeah, the bricks, I
guess. And Pitfall Harry kind
of looks like Mario
in Wrecking Crew. You know who he
reminds me of? He reminds me of
Blue Luigi.
The alternate costume
in Smash Bros. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm still wondering
though why they thought this game was so easy.
Yeah. Yeah, that's what I
was confused too. People could play it
in their sleep. I mean, I think it's
difficult unintentionally.
I think it will put
you to sleep. I don't think this is a
game people today would
have the same sort of
questioning the
reviewer of the past
where they think
something is so easy
and it's actually very
hard. But maybe that's just
our modern sensibilities
getting in the way. Yeah, maybe it's not
that it's particularly
difficult to avoid
enemies, but it's just
difficult to get your
objectives done and play
this game in general.
Yeah. I mean, it's also not
that easy. It's not crazy easy to
avoid enemies either. Yeah.
So this is where
Pitfall ends on the NES.
We will not be playing
another one. No.
But I just wanted to
talk about the sequels
and spinoffs section
for Super Pitfall
and Pitfall in general.
A sequel titled
Super Pitfall 2
was planned,
but then was canceled
a short time later.
I think it was probably
because of sales.
Yeah. It was going to be
a localized version of
Sunsoft's Famicom title
Atlantis Nonazo,
but I don't think
that would help.
Just stealing another
game and then saying
it's Super Pitfall 2.
If anything, it would confuse fans of
Super Pitfall, of which
there were none. Then we get Pitfall
the Mayan Adventure
on Super Nintendo
in 1994.
People like this game
though, right? People like this game
and it also plays a lot
more like Prince of
Persia. So I think that's why
at this time, Prince of Persia is now
a big deal.
Prince of Persia came to Super Nintendo as
well as it got ported
to everything. Yeah.
So I think now that
was more like, oh, Prince of Persia,
Pitfall, they go hand
in hand. Let's make a Super Pit,
let's make a Pitfall that's more like
Prince of Persia.
Then you get Pitfall 3D
Beyond the Jungle
for PlayStation and
emphasis on 3D here.
Please tell me it's like Tomb Raider.
It's, you know, I should tell you
what it's like, but I wanted to say
emphasis on 3D here
because it's also on the Game Boy Color.
Oh. Okay?
And I'm confused.
I don't really know
what that means. Yeah.
So just like in
Pitfall, the Mayan Adventure
and the original Pitfall
for the Atari 2600,
the Mayan Adventure
is a game set,
oh, no, it says just as in its,
I don't know what this
is trying to tell me right now,
but it's trying to tell me
that the original Pitfall
for the Atari 2600
is available as an Easter egg
for Pitfall,
the Mayan Adventure. Why that would be
the first thing mentioned in the gameplay
section of anybody's notes?
Is this the Wikipedia? Yeah, the official
Wikipedia article
lists what's included
as an Easter egg
before it ever talks about
what the game is about.
It must not be that good then.
The Mayan Adventure is a game set
in a 3D environment
which allows the player
character to move
in any direction.
Wow. Nobody played this game.
The player character
also has a much wider range of attacks,
some of which must be acquired
through item pickups.
Finally, item pickups
are a thing. Is there cover-based
shooting? There is not.
That was like
invented in Gears of War,
right? There's cover-based
shooting in this game. You jump into those pits
and you shoot. You shoot the spiders.
Right. First instance
of cover-based shooting.
I wish we could capture
how annoyed Sean looked.
He actually looked
like alarmed. He was looking around
like confused.
I just know that
cover-based shooting
was not invented
by the Gears of War people.
I just know that. Oh, you were annoyed
at that. Yeah. I thought you were annoyed
at the real people
who invented it. Since I can't give you
much about the gameplay,
I will tell you that the plot to Pitfall 3D
is that Pitfall Harry Jr.
meets a girl named Myra
who enlists his aid
in freeing her people
from the Scourge.
The Scourge?
Who sounds like
a tribe maybe
or like an alien entity.
Yeah. It refers to just
one evil woman
bent on controlling
the world. Oh, okay.
So it's a little bit
of like a step up
in the stakes.
And I'm getting...
It's set in a magical
parallel universe
where there are no...
No, this is all garbage.
They were like, if you think about
Crash Bandicoot,
this is like so... What?
This is just a
million out of thoughts.
I mean, it's like a fan just wrote this.
Right. Somebody just went on
like a rant one night
and said, if you think about
Crash Bandicoot,
this is way less linear.
It wasn't even meant
as the Pitfall
Wikipedia page. They just wrote something
and like, maybe I could tie this in
and include it
in the Pitfall Wikipedia page.
So the last game
we get is
Pitfall, The Lost Expedition.
It's for the sixth generation consoles.
It's GameCube,
PS2, and Xbox.
I don't want to even
look at what the gameplay is for this
kind of game, but I imagine that
like my opinion
is that GameCube
and PS2 and that stuff
is where things kind of got okay,
but I'm kind of done
with that gen of things.
Fifth and sixth generation
games to me at this
point in my life are unplayable.
I disagree,
but we can get into that at some other time.
Great. I think we should.
Maybe offline. Maybe I'll talk to you
offline. IRL?
IRL. If we're still friends.
That's all I have
for Pitfall sequels.
That's all I have for Pitfall development.
I think it is now time
for the Essential Games List.
Sam, I am dying to know
how you're going to vote for this game.
So can we just get on with it
and give me your vote? This game sucks.
But is it essential?
Yeah, nobody's ever done this
before. This is Leopardy.
You have to phrase it
correctly. But maybe he'll turn on us
and say, this game sucks
and I'm voting it.
But all games suck.
Everyone needs to experience
how bad this game sucks.
It's an essential experience
of suckage.
No, it's not. This game is real bad.
It's not essential.
The mechanics are bad.
This is a bad game.
Sean? Super Pitfall
is inessential.
It's a great example
of how not to design
a video game though.
So check it out
if you want to know that.
Joe? Have you ever had
a nightmare? And this game
is like playing
through a nightmare in a lot of ways.
So you're trying
to run somewhere.
It's hard to get there.
You're trying to jump.
You can't really
jump where you were trying to go.
Enemies are just popping out of nowhere.
The ceiling's falling on you.
I have more
and I can't think of it now.
The pyramids just show up
in people's dreams a lot.
The pyramids just show up.
You have a weapon
but you can't really attack
like you're trying to attack.
You can't actually attack anything.
And then at the end you finally finish it
and it just says please try again.
You just have to start over.
And meanwhile
that's haunting song.
One song over and over again.
It's just there was just nothing
enjoyable about this game.
So I'm going to say no. Super Pitfall
is now officially our second
fever dream game.
Sean do you remember
our first? No.
It was you who made the
allegation that
what was it
the burger game.
Oh burger time.
Burger time. The burger time
is just a chef's fever dream
after a day
of cooking burgers
that the ingredients
turn on him.
I do recall
saying that yes.
I will just say
that I am not
voting Super Pitfall
into the essential games list
and I'm not going
to justify why I'm just going to
tell you that so far we have
played 86 games
or 85 give or take
I put this one
at number 81
on my list.
So I think only five games
are worse. You got it
saying winter
games deadly towers
tag team
wrestling karate champ
and everybody's
favorite stack up
oh yeah
stack up
is awful
less essential
than this game. Super Pitfall
is at least a game.
We can all agree that
Super Pitfall is a game. It is debatable
if stack up
is a video game.
Right. That's all the
time we have for this episode
of Nostalgia.
Join us next
time for Top Gun
and we'll see
you there Maverick.
I'm Michael
Esposito. You can always
find more Nostalgia
on www.nostalgiacast.com
or our Twitter
at NostalgiaCast
or if you want
to really get in touch with us
you just use that
little contact
button on the website or hit us
right up at NostalgiaCast
at gmail.com.
We love hearing all your thoughts.
I'm Michael Esposito.
You can find me on at Esposito
Film on Twitter and we'll talk
to you soon. Are you Michael
Esposito? You're Mike
Esposito. You said earlier
you're dropping Michael Esposito.
I can't remember
if that was in the show or not. It's in the pre-show.
Okay. Alright. Good night.